hier soir donc dans le problème de la
vérité il ya eu une déclaration de série
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre la
question était simple
les questions étaient qu'elle est
l'animateur que vous avez le mois dans
le paf et il a fait sa réponse une
réponse pas la syrie l'un c'est cash
c'est clair assez nette on va la revoir
et on en reparle juste après
donnez moi le nom d'un grand animateur
nagui reichmann ce que tu veux voilà que
vous pouvez pas saquer j'exècre barthez
vraiment il a tout ce que je n'aime pas
n'est pas courageux
il balance pour aller en tête et quand
tu es devant lui bah il se retourne et
dix bombes à cheval au commissariat
voilà donc c'est tout ce que j'aime pas
moi j'aime les mecs qui ont des couilles
malheureusement il en a pas
je ne pensais pas qu'un jour j'aurai
honte d'avoir travaillé à canal+
aujourd'hui c'est le cas tout mon
soutien aux salariés du groupe canal et
pour ceux qui ont le doute une journée
voilà donc ça c'était là la réponse de m
il ya eu les vocations de cyril valery
vous connaissez très bien chez rhinois
qu'est ce qui peut expliquer parce qu'il
ya tout ça a une origine des
explications pour quoi sert il a déclaré
cette chose vous savez à quel point sert
il est mon ami à quel point je crois
bien le connaître et c'est pas gratuit
en fait il ya vraiment un élément
déclencheur qui est il ya quelques temps
de ça en fait
yann barthès a fait un sketch et dans ce
sketch où il se moquait pas simplement
de tpm paix ou même des chroniqueurs
quand bien même ça aurait fait de la
peine à cyril mais là en l'occurrence il
s'est moqué des téléspectateurs qui
regardaient touche pas à mon poste et
ciré sall a infiniment blessé parce que
on peut le dire tout ce qu'on veut sur
lui ça glisse comme sur les les plumes
d'un canard cyril était très fort et il
sait que ça que le nord non mais voilà
il sait que c'est la loi du métier et
qu'on peut ne pas l'apprécier et c'est
en revanche qu'on touche ou à ses
chroniqueurs ou au public qui regarde en
disant que ce sont des crétins on est en
étant extrêmement j'allais dire
condescendant vraiment et en les
méprisant sa salle a énormément blessée
et à partir de là il n'a pas pardonné à
yann barthès de s'être attaqué à qui
n'ont pas à luis mercé casas sont à son
public on va avoir des touches parle
dans les images c'est la peur vraiment
raconter là c'est parce qu'évidemment
india une suite le regarder et bibi à
table il ya baba qui commence cette
phrase qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup parlé
regardez voilà plus de place pour le
sans abri mais ans
même temps les centre pour migrants
continuent à ouvrir partout en france
martèle qui était en direct donc que les
diables endroits dits oui n'a pas du
tout repris ce type qui est typiquement
ce genre de choses mais gravi qu'il
devrait reprendre et en faire quelque
chose et baby là le mec de love story
qui dit que barthez il n'y en a pas
parlé sur l'a10 je pense que l élève la
production a eu un petit appel
on fait attention à jean pire ou le haut
alpin baby ya baba qui dit que barthez
il a eu un coup de fil de tf1 voilà donc
sa page 9
j'avais pas vu le sketch nam et où les
rejoint cyril dans son analyse du bien
être serré où je sais à quel point ça me
fait vraiment série pour passer le
publiant oui voilà alors et ça ça la
salle a vraiment l'air très quoi
vraiment automne à une attaque contre
contre canach et quand même honnêtement
pour avoir fait la première année du
grand jour noir avec lui il aggravant de
bassa avant de parler de ça sa suite la
suite à ce sketch cyril alors c'est vrai
que le style de série dont on connaît
tous on est tous concernés
quand il a un truc à vous dire pas se
mentir il y va ils ont laissé un message
d'un message mais ferait bon il est
sanguin comme ça qu'il a essayé de
contacter qui lui a raccroché au nez et
ça pour le coup il n'y a pas eu de
discussion n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu
débat il c'est une fin de non-recevoir
je veux pas de pareils creek forcément
série ça l'a énervé et ce qui est je
crois encore plus blessants c'est qu'à
l'origine faut vous dire qu'il y avait
un pacte d un agresseur non agression
entre entre tp mp et l'émission
quotidien et encore une fois moi je suis
absolument infiniment persuadé que si
yann barthès est attaquée à cyril à
dominer mais l'animateur cyril aurait
voilà et ce serait une guerre entre
guillemets traditionnel mais là de
s'attaquer au public je connais vraiment
cyril et je sais que cela l'a prouvé
avoir évolué j'ai donc dans la mesure
tout à fait vrai juste revenir sur la
phrase j'ai honte d'avoir travaillé à
cannes pression mais moi j'ai honte
d'entendre barthez critiqué son ancien
employeur je trouve ça absolument
scandaleux ça c'est digne d'un petit
parce qu on ne crache pas dans la soupe
après en avoir largement profité
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire
il mérite pas plus
c'est pas faux et je vois pas le rapport
avec le soutien saynètes bureau pas bon
bref on a justement les débats le
premier passage de monsieur barthez
c'était donc à cannes a plus non lors du
petit journal actu et cette année yann
barthès est avec lui
[Applaudissements]
on nous a dit qu'il n'y avait pas d'
éléphant aux universités d'été du ps ce
week end à la rochelle
on nous a menti nous on en a croisé la
preuve on a vu laurent fabius en
débardeur bernard kouchner qui s'est
fait rêver color lionel jospin tout
tombe il est
strauss-kahn de dos et martine aubry
voilà pour les débuts de yann barthès
sur sur canal+ alors il ya oui un truc
intéressant c'est une histoire se
interflora wim expliquer ce qui s'est
passé avec interflora sur interflora
yannick brousse
j'ai pas tout compris qui s'est passé un
deal qui était rigolo je crois à c'était
un tout
regardez regardez regardez regardez
regarde donc dire aux gars drogue à
l'europe via malabo hanouna et barthez
est ce que c'était mission serait cette
émission sans les blocages à interflora
francesco coûté pmp voilà on postale
assez mignon ça c'est mignon voilà on
finit en fleurs et en oui il faut quand
même préciser qu'il a une communité une
communauté de fans qui sont les fans
chaussures sur twitter et trois millions
cinq cent mille abonnés je crois qu'ils
sont abonnés à tpm paix qui sont fans de
tpm paix je pense qu'il a la communauté
la plus grande de france cyril qui avec
il est très proche et il donne beaucoup
on le sait donc effectivement s'attaquer
à trois millions cinq cent mille
personnes c'est un peu déconné et c'est
quand même hyper hypocrite et comme il
le dit toujours serré lille ya de la
place pour tout le monde dans la vie il
veut pas et c'est normal ils n'ont pas
qu'on touche à ses téléspectateurs à son
audience comme on dit en amérique voilà
je pense que le débat pour l'instant est
clos mais oui évidemment série de sera
lalinde et donc je ne peux que et
d'autres épisodes dit si d'ici là des
fois oui c'est ça qui est touchant juste
un dernier mot c'est un homme blessé là
cyril c'est ça c'est ça c'est ce sa
blessure profonde
les petits bobos nuit vraiment il ça
c'est touchant chez lui et je comprends
pourquoi la véhémence de ces propos
justement parce que ces cas et or si on
te fais plein de bisous pour moi
[Applaudissements]